so
back to what i was saying before
my theory oh god um steve rogers did not
have a girlfriend before he went into
the service
says who
the history channel so he becomes
captain america and from that moment on
a symbol of america he is rushed to the
front lines he becomes a war hero then
he is frozen in ice right so based on
everything you've told me
after he gets unfrozen he goes from
world threatening disaster to world
threatening disaster that's when he's
not a fugitive from the law right so it
seems like he was pretty pretty busy all
you're doing is repeating everything
that i've already told you about my
friend and golly obviously captain
america was a virgin
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and this exclusive clip
was released by imdb today and i really
really love this clip for so many
reasons there are so many different
easter eggs and setups in this one
minute video it is crazy awesome from
talking about captain america being a
virgin which is something that you would
never really think marvel studios would
talk about but she hulk is going to to
possibly giving us a setup for the next
solo hulk movie which is rumored to be
world war hulk this clip has so much to
it and it's funny and we get the origin
story of she-hulk so let's jump into the
breakdown and talk about all of these
easter eggs and the setup for the next
solo hulk film and of course if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so this clip is hilarious
because we essentially get the origin of
she-hulk here and the reason it kind of
all happens is because she's making fun
of steve rogers captain america so we
start off with jennifer walters and her
cousin bruce banner aka the hulk in the
car and jennifer states that she has a
theory and the theory is about captain
america and the theory is that captain
america is a virgin and it's kind of
funny because she presents facts and
evidence to support her case which is
funny because she's a lawyer that's what
she does professionally that's what she
does for a living she argues facts and
evidence and you can see that she
clearly brings that into her personal
life as well but it's also hilarious
because bruce banner has known steve
rogers for a while and has been through
so much with him and he was even there
when he went back in time stayed back in
time but then came back to give the
shield to sam so bruce banner has really
been by steve rogers aside for a while
with the exception of the time that he
went away after age of ultron but he's
listening to her and he's kind of
laughing and shaking his head because
this is his friend and she is coming up
with these pretty crazy theories that
actually kind of seem to be true at
least before avengers end game hopefully
after avengers in game once he got with
peggy the virgin thing went away i'm
assuming it did but if you're not paying
attention one detail that you might have
missed is the sling on bruce banner's
arm his arm is still hurt from avengers
end game where he snapped and it
permanently damaged his arm it seems
like now what's interesting is that he
is not even in the hulk form in this
shot and pretty much every time that
we've seen him in a trailer or a clip he
is the hulk specifically professor hulk
which is how we left him after end game
but during end game at the end professor
hulk still had the sling on his arm also
not to mention that in shanghai and the
legend of the ten rings as post credit
scene we see bruce banner via hologram
and he still has the sling on his arm
there as well so something seemingly
happens during she-hulk that allows
bruce banner to fully recover and heal
his arm and it could actually come down
to what happens immediately after this
car crash now another reason i find this
funny is because this is the origin
story of she-hulk and jennifer walters
basically becomes she-hulk because she
was kind of making fun of steve rogers
let me explain this origin is a little
bit different from the comics but
reflects it a lot because in the comics
bruce banner is having a hard time being
the hulk so he decides to pay his cousin
a visit because she was always easy to
talk to so he goes and he visits her but
a man by the name of nicholas trask
hires people to kill jennifer walters
because she is defending a client that
he is at odds with so he pays people to
go and kill her and she does get shot
but bruce banner is there and he ends up
taking her away and he goes to a
hospital and he decides that she needs a
blood transfusion so he gives her his
blood which is in turn how she becomes
she-hulk and it actually is what saves
her life now obviously this is a little
bit different here but you can see how
the origin story reflects it in the mcu
now now here is a huge huge detail that
has so many implications for the future
of the mcu and that is the ship that
shows up and causes them to crash if you
notice this is the exact same ship that
the grand master had in thor ragnarok
it's not his ship but it's the same
exact design you can see that the paint
is a little bit different but the model
of the ship is exactly the same so this
ship is most likely from sakaar this
could mean that this ship has come from
the grand master the grand master still
could be hunting for his champion as he
called the hulk and it looks like he
finally tracked him down on earth this
means that the cause of the accident was
actually because somebody was trying to
assassinate or kidnap and bring back to
zakar bruce banner not jennifer walters
but here's what this means for the mcu
and how it could actually set up world
war hulk the story of world war hulk in
the comics starts by the illuminati
actually banishing bruce banner to a
different planet they actually trick him
the illuminati deems that he is too
dangerous to keep on earth so they
essentially trick him into going into
outer space but then they just kind of
shoot him past the moon and send him to
another planet and the planet that he
ends up on is sakar from there on out he
actually becomes gladiator hulk on zakar
and that's what we saw in thor ragnarok
however he ends up becoming the king of
the planet he gets a wife she gets
pregnant but the ship that the
illuminati sent him to the planet on
ends up exploding killing his wife and
his unborn child and the hulk is
obviously furious so he heads back to
earth stopping on the moon to defeat
black bolt the king of the inhumans and
then going to the earth and defeats
pretty much every hero there is and this
hulk is super strong because he absorbs
so much radiation on the planet zakar
now of course this show is going to be
about she-hulk if we've learned anything
from the other shows it's that marvel
studios when they do a disney plus
series about a specific character or
characters they stick to the story about
the characters so i'm not assuming we're
going to dive too much into sakaar in
she-hulk however i do think this is a
big setup for the next hulk movie
clearly people on sakhar whether that's
the grand master or anybody else are
searching for the hulk and this could
eventually lead him going back to sakhar
or it could lead to people that he loves
getting hurt like in this opening scene
here the ship causes the crash that
leads to jennifer walters needing the
blood transfusion from bruce banner and
her becoming she-hulk so obviously she
gets so hurt in this crash that she's
gonna die unless she gets a blood
transfusion from bruce banner and this
is obviously going to piss bruce banner
off and he's going to go what the heck
why are people searching for me and i'm
betting that he tries to figure out what
is behind all of this or who is behind
all of this we do see the hulk a lot in
the trailers for the show but that could
all be from the very first episode when
he's just kind of helping jennifer get
used to being a hulk and showing her
what she can actually do her potential
and i actually wouldn't be surprised if
bruce banner and the hulk were only in
one or two episodes and then he dips and
heads to sakaar so he can find out why
people are hunting him down and that
could be the setup for the next hulk
movie and honestly i really hope it
happens because i'm ready to see a true
hulk rage out and tear people apart now
another interesting thing about this
clip is that we don't actually see bruce
banner turn into the hulk during the
accident which you would think would
happen but if you look closely at bruce
banner you can see that he has a device
on his left arm we can't be 100 sure
what this device is however this could
be a device that kind of prevents him
from turning into the hulk perhaps he
uses this when he's out in public in
case he gets angry it prevents him from
turning into the hulk so he doesn't
really have to worry about it after all
everybody knows who bruce banner is at
this point in time they know that he's
the hulk so they might get a little
uncomfortable around him in public yes
he's a hero but at the same time the
hulk has caused a lot of destruction in
the world so perhaps this is just a
safety measure now i'm assuming that
after the crash bruce does turn into the
hulk so he can save himself and then his
cousin plus not to mention i'm sure he
would hulk out being pissed that the
ship caused this crash and hurt his
cousin to a near fatal point and maybe
from then on out he just chooses to
remain in hulk form or maybe he can't
get himself to go back to bruce banner
form we'll have to wait and see on that
but in the meantime let me know what you
think about this clip i think it's
pretty awesome and i think it's really
funny as well jennifer walters is going
to break the fourth wall in she-hulk so
i'm really excited for that and i hope
it's funny so leave your thoughts down
below and don't forget to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news and videos for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me